hey guys first of all thank you for
clicking you're about to watch a new
video or another video on YouTube and
before you do - 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 31 if you
are getting value out of my youtube
videos what I'm doing in my text
community is bonkers it's instant it's
access its exclusive and it's just been
a lot of fun and I've just enjoyed
texting back and forth with a lot of you
- 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 I'm sure they're
editing something team I know how you do
it please join my texting community and
now enjoy this YouTube video you could
always go back into the [ __ ] you know
how to do I'm so confused by this like
no [ __ ] I'm aware that you don't want it
to not work it just might and as long as
you have a relationship with winning and
losing you're good this is about having
a relationship with losing the amount of
insecurity that's out there is absurd
people are scared about losing - who who
the [ __ ] are you scared of losing kid
what's gonna happen your mama's gonna
call you be like you're a [ __ ] loser
I told you you should have been a nurse
[ __ ] you mom you got your perspective
I wanna be happy don't you want to be
happy
[Music]
who's buying your product primary
salesperson or smaller LinkedIn bro you
need to make a hot you need to make 25
piece of content a day for LinkedIn
specific when people think of
salespeople is one thing versus a sales
woman who happens to be a Falcons fan
that's a whole different you can my game
is in perpetuity
people like sales people and I'm like
I'm gonna know they're like how do I
make a hundred pieces of content like
okay well first of all there's 50 states
so there's 50 hey Alabama hey sales
people in Alabama it's your boy that's
already 50 because I can promise you
when you run ads against small
businesses or sales organization in
Alabama and it starts with what's up
Alabama that already does better than it
says what's up its your boy Gary I know
it's true you start then saying you said
then do that piece of content when the
Auburn Alabama game is going on and you
make some sort of reference point that
says if you're an Auburn fan and leave a
comment or if you're a Bama fan leave a
comment and LinkedIn whoever wins the
game that person gets 10% off the other
one gets to cry twice
and so if you look at the collective
reaction to that idea that's why I win
because I'm in the game of ideas and
then just making [ __ ]
LinkedIn is uncomfortably underpriced
organic let alone paid you need to go
if you made no content anywhere else
which is so against my macro thesis but
if you didn't and you made a hundred
piece a day for LinkedIn that was
specific to psychographic demographic
location age gender sex you will win
it's really I know it well and what's
really awesome for me is it's gonna work
good it's kind of like believing that if
you eat well and you workout every day
you'll look better I know you believe it
I'm telling you to [ __ ] do it
[Music]
nothing meaning meaning you can't
imagine you know what that would be like
if if we were like kids and only wanted
to eat candy and I literally walked in
right now with a [ __ ] truck full of
candy and you'd be like yo where else is
there candy I'm like [ __ ] we
can't eat all this candy that was that
was the question
yep yes but bring them value well like
that's a challenge too you know like
that's not so easy
start digging it and then start correct
and then start reading comments ask
questions one of the things that very
few people do is make content to ask
questions I love that because then you
get answers in the comments which then
leads you to the next piece of content
so much of my content is actually not
made for any other thing than an insight
to a hypothesis it's how I got to all
the content that I talked about today I
there was no strategy session where I'm
like I'm gonna make content about
parenting that was a thing that happened
out of making all the content that made
me get to the realization of so many
opportunities and vulnerabilities that's
why it resonates the reason my content
resonates is it comes from the community
[Music]
you've been enjoying this like raising
us it's a happy nice inside peek of the
world that you love so much
Atlanta 3 what is it a 3 you know when
you think about the importance of using
tech music and culture the reality is is
it's like cooking a perfect meal you
know if you're missing an ingredient
you're limiting the upside and the
reality is when you think about those
three sectors they're the foundation of
where society's attention and execution
is so to me the importance is like any
perfect meal you need all the
ingredients when I think about things
like a3c and other things like it the
number-one thing that comes to mind is
if you're not putting yourself out there
and going to the things that are
educating inspiring and allowing you to
have fuel to execute I think you're
limiting yourself and so for me my last
parting shot is like go out and do
Network meet consume and then most of
all execute you know what's good fam it
scary be a big shout-out to the garyvee
espanol community big shout out to this
man right here [ __ ] brains and looks
look at this dude behind this operation
I just want to say thank you so much
sorry I failed on my Spanish clashes
otherwise I would have dropped something
on you but I got them we're here live
that life you got one of them [ __ ]
execute you know follow this man he's
doing it you can do it everybody can
[ __ ] do it
there ain't nothing [ __ ] stopping you
except your [ __ ] dome bet if I could
rap I'm such a good storyteller I could
do so much fun [ __ ] it would be so good
probably like a little boy in a lemonade
stand
[Applause]
good
what is good I love when the haters come
out on me and be like don't was this
fool he got [ __ ] [ __ ] given to a
[ __ ] I got nothing given to me I
got the right to work 18 hours a day 365
days a year for my dad and then leave at
34 with no [ __ ] money that's the
right guy but what I knew is the [ __ ]
that I speak to you which is you're
young I knew that I wanted to give back
to my parents because I was grateful as
[ __ ] that they took me out of that
[ __ ] Soviet Union I knew that at 34
that I was still young I know that
[ __ ] young at 43 I think I'm young if
you're [ __ ] by [ __ ] do business
with seventy eight year olds these
[ __ ] sent there within another
hundred years
it's mindset bro I don't understand I
got people that are 28 they're like oh
[ __ ] in two years my life's over and
then there's people that are 82 and like
man I'm building some [ __ ] that's gonna
launch in 30 years I'm like [ __ ]
gave me death mindset we do not have a
good relationship with time we don't
we're impatient we're impatient because
we care about what other people think
about us that's the [ __ ] game you
know it I know it we're doing way too
much [ __ ] based on other people's
[ __ ] opinion and the only thing that
I got lucky with is when I was 26 and I
was carrying out a case of champagne for
my friends when they would stop by the
liquor store and they would laugh at me
when they went in the car cuz I was
working for my dad's liquor store and I
was such a loser the only thing that
went through my mind is laughs now
mother
because I'm not worried that I'm down 20
points in the first quarter this [ __ ]
only Anglin triple zero hit the [ __ ]
clock and so I highly recommend cuz I
got so much love for this loop for real
for real
that all of you realize it's not even
half time it's not even [ __ ] a half
time and so for me let me make you one
promise this evening you find what
you're looking for you want to find
negativity it's easy as [ __ ] you want to
find positivity it's actually easy as
[ __ ] my big thing is that I'm trying to
get other people that are happy and
positive and optimistic to post more
about it's the biggest fact we are loud
as [ __ ] about negativity and we're quiet
as [ __ ] about positivity and if I lead
with anything here we need to change
that dynamic this is what people are so
[ __ ] confused because people are
quick to spit negativity but they keep
positivity in them which is like every
day I take on the responsibility to go
the other way because it's in me I'm
grateful I'm grateful for the at-bat I
was born in the Soviet Union that place
[ __ ] sucked [ __ ] I got lucky
get the [ __ ] out and I'm grateful I'm
grateful to you know if you know I don't
know if any of you've seen this video
but it's one of my favorite things I put
out the math behind being alive is crazy
400 trillion to one 400 trillion to one
you were more likely to win the lotto
seven times in your life tend to be in
this [ __ ] room
like your mom could have got up for
another glass of wine
like it could like you could have been a
[ __ ] tree
[Music]
what makes you happy because look you're
talking to somebody who does 800 things
because my theory is like if I've got
800 balls in the air and let's actually
make it real if I've got 44 balls in the
air I'm ok with 7 breaking cuz hey I
don't give a [ __ ] about your judgment on
those else and that's the big one and 2
I still got 37 balls in the air and
that's how I like to juggle other people
are type a really they just enjoy one
thing head down there is the right
answer the reason I said it's a [ __ ]
so you need to set you don't need 7
streams of income
yeah good there's a [ __ ] so enjoy it Bo
be happy as long as you can deal with
the judgment that when you talk [ __ ]
that your [ __ ] burger business was
gonna kill it but then it was one of the
things that dropped because you were
worried about something else as long as
you can deal with those else then just
make yourself happy
I'm not worried if my wine on my kinks
is for this I'm not worried what fails
the [ __ ] does that have to do with you
judging by else this is about having a
relationship with losing the amount of
insecurity that's out there is absurd
people are scared about losing to who
who the [ __ ] are you scared of losing
kid what's gonna happen your mama's
going to call you be like you're a
[ __ ] loser I told you you should have
been a nurse [ __ ] you mom
who losses it besides yours because I'm
promising something right now my dear
the number one thing every [ __ ]
person in here should be worried about
is regret you want some real poison
you want some sip that really hurts
waking up to 80 and you'll regret that
you didn't [ __ ] try I know you know
why because you people she's spending
more time with elderly that aren't their
family you speak to elderlies and aren't
your family you see one theme regret
they don't talk about what they did they
talk about what they didn't do so what
go go hard in Atlanta ATL everything's
happening here you go hard you go at it
real hard for a couple years three four
five whatever your patience is based on
finances what you want in your life and
if you decide to go back at least when
you're 92 you're sitting there me like
man I wish you don't get I wish out of
your mouth and Lana thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy - happy to help anybody you want
me to talk to next year that you try to
recruit I'll get on the phone with you
like do this event I mean and are you I
don't know enough about the weather are
you able to go back in a year or two of
you okay so that's honestly that's we
like honestly that makes me so happy cuz
I wasn't sure if I go [ __ ] I don't know
if they're like you have to rely on that
you have to know that you know that it
was stability
you're gonna go chase your dream now
just like I told that young lady with
the you know with the nursing stuff
you're good go hard at this you're in
the right [ __ ] City go on guard but
you know what don't even don't even
think of it that way that's more like
damn if I have to go back I lost don't
even think about that instead be like
you know that's always there for me for
so you're young you're young as [ __ ]
that will always be there for me and
what that then does is it makes it look
like it makes it look like a nice stable
thing if needed versus I [ __ ] up you
know don't demon I first of all don't
demonize something that you're doing for
all of us for real at number two this
will give you more time to do your thing
the biggest mistake that people make
when they come out of military out of
school and have a job that only got a
bad relationship
is they don't give themself enough time
to
new [ __ ] like I always worry about the
fact I graduate on stage and I was
worried about the financial side of
things versus like actually chasing the
happiness that comes down to spending
money if you can live more humble you
can hold your breath longer I just want
to tell everybody people are giving up
on their dreams by buying [ __ ] Easy's
like if you can afford it buy [ __ ]
benzo I don't give a [ __ ] but if you
can't but if you can't and it's buying
[ __ ] that made you have to go back then
you [ __ ] up if you can afford it buy
anything buy a Lambo buy a [ __ ] buy
an island I don't give a [ __ ] of it but
if you're buying [ __ ] that then takes
you out of being able to chase your
dream you're [ __ ] up so like really
be thoughtful about your money and do
some a side hustle [ __ ] the flippin
stuff I talked about get a job that
[ __ ] sucks but it lets you chase your
dream longer and then you've always got
the last thing there but be patient it's
impatience I'm telling you people are
patient
[Music]
know what off it scary be free game
radio podcast [ __ ]
introduction
reason you are a reason right
how's that bubble goes I love you boy
good job
[Music]
[ __ ] phenomenal day long operational
business day in Chattanooga and then
came to the a and [ __ ] dropped it so
much love in the room this [ __ ] town
I can't tell you how much love I have
for it I can't wait for you to watch
this thing and drop me any single
comment or hit me up on social what you
thought and text me two one two nine
three one five seven three one we love
the a and the a loves us it's crazy that
was that was just cool good you know
what I mean I felt like it was important
I will be on your podcast are you saying
that you do you do you do 50 of your own
podcast you're on or or you hit me up on
social once a week and be like go on the
good-looking dude with the hair and from
a VA and I'll just pick one random time
to have you on so so 50 of my own it's
gonna do me like so I gotta get on this
freedom get me on you know you're not
doing that either
Gary's whoa
[Music]